well I'd like to start by thanking
Costas and the other program committee
members for inviting me to participate
in this great gathering and thank all of
you for for coming as Costas mentioned
I'm an economist focusing on economic
behavior if particularly financial
economic behavior but I think that the
topic I'm going to take today actually
fits very well with the theme of this
workshop on algorithmic game theory and
practice I'm actually going to be
talking about both theory and practice
in ways that I'm hoping is going to be
quite consistent with not only the
workshop but the science Symons
Institute the theory of computing so let
me begin with a little bit of motivation
the motivation is really the start of
game theory which of course is von
Neumann and Morgenstern and Paul
Samuelson in 1947 the pair of books that
came out the theory of games and
economic behavior and Samuelson's
foundations of economic analysis really
outlined for the next several
generations what economists were going
to be taking as the basic workhorse of
how to model economic behavior namely
expected utility maximization maximizing
and expected utility functions subject
to a budget constraint so this is a
theory that we still teach our PhD
students in economics it's pretty much
the only theory that economists will use
certainly in financial economics and
it's only over the course of the last
few years that we've begun chipping away
at this incredibly successful edifice
and the chipping away has to do with the
fact that in practice these theories
don't work expected utility maximization
fall short in any number of contexts and
in some early work that my co-author
Craig McKinley and I did years ago we
showed that for example the random walk
hypothesis which is part of this edifice
of predicting economic behavior under
certain circumstances that can easily be
rejected in the data and many other
documented departures from rationality
and the theory of expected utility has
come through by psychologists and
behavioral economists
so I'm gonna give you an example of one
of these violations because it seems so
strange particularly given what we think
of as normal rational behavior it has to
do with something called probability
matching some of you who studied
psychology or behavioral finance might
have come across this but otherwise you
may not have it's a simple game where
I've got a coin and I toss it one after
another and you try to guess whether
it's going to be heads or tails at each
toss and if you're correct I pay you a
dollar and if you're not correct you pay
me a dollar and we're gonna do this
multiple times and I'll tell you right
now that it's my coin that we're gonna
use and it's not necessarily a fair coin
in fact what happens is after several
tosses you notice that it comes up heads
about three times more frequently than
tails so empirically you observe that
it's roughly 75% heads 25% tails so
question what is the rational economic
strategy that you would undertake once
you observe this empirical fact what
should you guess heads all the time
of course that will maximize your
expected winnings when you actually try
this out on subjects it turns out that
people don't do this they don't do heads
all the time what they do is this
they actually randomized and oddly
enough the frequency with which they
pick tails actually matches the 7525
split they will pick head 75% of the
time and pig tails 25% of time and
what's even more interesting is that if
some time during the sequence of games
you switch the coin surreptitiously from
a 7525 coin to a 60/40 coin after
another 10 or 20 trials they actually
change to 60/40 they will match the
probability and what's even more
stunning is that this behavior is found
not just in humans but in ants fish
pigeons primates virtually any creature
that can choose between a versus B will
actually behave in this manner they will
engage in this probability matching and
so the question is why
is this the case this seems so
irrational from an economic perspective
and given that it's in common with so
many different species there has to be a
deeper explanation so my co-authors and
I Tom Brennan narrations on we started
looking at this and trying to understand
what the underpinnings are of behavior
and so let me just give you a quick
summary and then I'll dive into the
results what we do in a series of papers
some of which are published others of
which are ongoing you can find them on
my website and we cite them in the
slides you all welcome to have a copy
what we've come to is an explanation
that really tries to address the
question of where these behaviors come
from what are their origins why are they
there are they created equal or do they
have differences and what we've
concluded is that there is a very simple
framework for explaining all of these
things from an evolutionary perspective
so what we do is to provide a framework
where we can derive risk aversion loss
aversion randomization mixed strategies
all sorts of behavioral anomalies that
economists feel are not consistent with
expecting utility maximization we can
derive those behaviors in a very
primitive way and I'll describe to you
how primitive it is based on the simple
model that we use and so we argue that
behavioral biases the irrationalities
that we document in financial markets
are really hardwired forms of
adaptations that may seem irrational
from the narrow perspective of financial
decision making but when you look at it
from a broader perspective you
understand why they're there it doesn't
mean that they're any less irrational
from that perspective but at least we
understand why they're there and why it
may be impossible to eliminate them
unless you change the environment and
the environment is really the key to
understanding behavior what we're going
to show is that it's the underlying risk
of reproduction that will explain a lot
of the emergence of these kinds of
behaviors and its different kinds of
risk that explain different kinds of
behavior so that's sort of the nature of
the narrative and in particular I want
to distinguish between two kinds of
systematic risk versus idiosyncratic
risk these are very much along the same
lines of what financial economists have
been thinking about but it's done in a
very very different context this is a
much more of a biological and
evolutionary context so that framework
will then provide a very natural
definition for what intelligence is and
what the bounds on intelligence might be
so we're going to ultimately come back
full circle to what Herbert Simon
proposed decades ago on this bounded
rationality and satisficing behavior
we're going to provide an evolutionary
foundation for his work and it
ultimately forms the mathematical basis
for what I've been calling over the last
few years the adaptive markets
hypothesis those of you who've studied
finance in any bit you probably run
across the efficient markets hypothesis
most people in practice don't believe
the efficient markets hypothesis because
they know that investors can actually
make money under certain circumstances
with the right kinds of technologies and
that flies in the face of efficiency
this framework will actually provide a
nice resolution of that contradiction I
won't have time to do a thorough
literature review the work we do cuts
across lots of different literature's we
cite the relevant papers in our study so
you're welcome to take a look at it but
one of the literature's that it does
very much overlap with this evolutionary
game theory and algorithmic game theory
mechanism design I'll make a few of
those connections along the way ok so
let me first start with a very simple
model and once you see how simple it is
you'll understand what I mean when I say
this is a very primitive explanation for
how these kinds of behaviors emerge the
model is a very simple binary choice
model I'm gonna start with a group of
asexual semelparous individuals that's a
very fancy way of saying I'm going to
talk about objects that don't engage in
any kind of sexual reproduction they
simply give birth to multiple offspring
and they give birth only once in their
life and they die so these are not
necessarily humans these could be
bacteria or just general theoretical
creatures that we won't really need to
worry about for a moment I'll come back
and talk a bit about the realism a
little bit later on so these individuals
they live in one period and then they
make one decision in their
lifetime's choosing between a versus B
these are two generic choices they could
be where to nest
they could be foraging strategies they
could be all sorts of different kinds of
behavior but I'm going to call that a
versus B and that decision determines
the number of offspring that they will
have they'll either get XA which is a
random variable or they'll get xB which
is another random variable and the only
assumption I'm going to make about their
behavior is that the offspring behave
exactly like their parents so there's
perfect genetic transmission if you will
there's no mutation there's no
differentiation the parents are going to
transmit their behavior perfectly to the
next generation and so what do I mean by
behavior what I mean by behavior is how
you choose between a versus B I'm gonna
assume a really simple minded behavior
which is that these individuals engage
in Bernoulli trials they will choose a
with probability F and they will choose
B with probability 1 minus F and so this
parameter F is really what defines
behavior in this very simple context and
I'm gonna assume that F can be anything
between 0 & 1 including 0 or 1 so you
can have deterministic behavior
individuals that always pick a for them
F is equal to 1 individuals that always
pick B for them F equals 0 individuals
that choose 50/50 F is equal to 1/2 and
the only thing you have to know about
behavior here is that the parents and
the children have the exact same F okay
now the behavior has nothing to do with
the random variables I'm assuming that
this choice of a versus B is completely
statistically independent of everything
and anything in the entire system here
okay so you can think of it it's just
mindless choice behavior of a versus B
and little X is the number of offspring
you will get if you choose a and little
X B is the number of offspring you will
get if you choose B and X and XA and xB
are both random variable
okay and in a minute I'll assume
something about their statistical
distribution but for now all you need to
know is that they're different random
variables right different different
distributions yes right a result of the
outcome they will inherit the mix
strategy that's right
exactly right yes and so I'm assuming
that how you behave which is summarized
by F that's what's inherited by your
offspring by all of your offspring all
of them will be the same F once enough
always an F okay it's like I chose B but
I had a random strategy and that's
what's right that's right well well I
mean I think there's a semantic subtlety
here and the semantics subtlety that I'm
adopting is that behavior is F F could
be a mixed strategy but it could also be
a deterministic strategy so but it's the
F that matters yes that's right now what
biologists care about though is not so
much F what they would care about is the
X a in the X B and as an economist I
have no interest in that all I care
about is the statistical distributions
the properties of XA and xB as it
relates to behavior F so I'm gonna
summarize XA and xB by this Joint
Distribution function
I'm simply gonna assume that it exists
it's well-defined it's got some
reasonable properties that will allow me
to compute means and variances and
that's about it
otherwise it's absolutely general so all
of the information about the environment
about the resources about the biology of
reproduction about the genetic
transmission all of that is subsumed by
this distribution function
it does not f is totally statistically
well F is not a random variable but it
is completely devoid of any kind of
relationship any systematic relationship
with the distribution or XA or xB so
it's literally totally mindless behavior
okay so the idea is that I start out
with this individual that chooses using
this parameter F and I let the
individual reproduce over many many
generations and after a while I get a
bunch of F's so what I want to do is to
start with all possible FS between 0 & 1
including 0 & 1 and let them reproduce
and over time I want to see whether or
not there's any particular F that seems
to be over-represented the one that
grows the fastest will be the one that I
claim from an evolutionary perspective
dominates and that is the behavior that
I'm claiming is selected by evolution
exactly right yes so you start off you
know going left or right with a
particular F and then your offspring
will do the same and they'll do the same
and the same in the same and after a
while you just get a whole bunch of
different f's
if you start off with the same number of
each type you can get the C over time
whether or not there is an F that
dominates now it turns out that there is
an F that dominates in this case it's
the green one F 4 but in practice if you
assume something about the distribution
Phi you can actually get a very explicit
expression for the F that emerges out of
this evolutionary process so let me
first assume that this distribution Phi
of XA and xB I'm going to assume that it
is identical within a generation and
independent and identical across
generations
we just spend a minute describing the
intuition for that it weren't part of
the same generation then what it means
to say that it's identical is that if
you pick a you're gonna get XA if I pick
a I'm gonna get the very same X a not
just the same distribution the same
outcome it's the same random variable
it's identical distributions right
instead I could have assumed that we
have identical and independent
distribution so if you pick a you get
your draw of XA and I get a separate
independent draw from the same
distribution I'm not assuming that in
this case I'm assuming we get the actual
same realization okay so the way that
you can think of it from a biological
perspective is we're part of the same
ecosystem and therefore if we choose the
same path because of our comparable
biologies we get the same number of
offspring no no assumptions about that
that's actually gonna be that'll come in
later we're gonna derive that as a
result so I'm gonna assume that this
distribution is identical across
individuals but over time the next
generation they get their own draw of XA
xB so statistically its independent over
time but it's dependent it's perfectly
dependent cross-sectionally within a
given generation
I worry that if the decision wasn't
synchronous then depending on the timing
somehow I would see oxa was good
therefore I will pick well so yes well I
mean implicitly I'm assuming that these
decisions are being made within a single
generation
at the same time that's right sure
exactly but there's no there's no gaming
here there's no intelligence here
there's no strategy going on you have to
really think about these is dumb little
bacteria not to insult bacteria in the
audience but just think about this as
mindless which is in this case a feature
not a bug okay so individuals are
mindless they're not optimizers yeah
sorry buddy pun intended
which which F survives in this in this
very simple frame er can you cut can you
find an F that survives over many many
generations beyond all other f's
it turns out that what I've described
just now you can actually calculate what
Ernst Meier called
you know the principle of evolution the
fact that it's the process of
elimination you can find an F that grows
the fastest in just what I've described
and that F star the one that that has
the maximal growth rate that's the
behavior that emerges through this very
very artificial evolutionary selection
process okay so let me show you how I
have to do a little bit of population
arithmetic I'm not going to take you
through the math but it's pretty
straightforward actually the number of
type F at time T in the population is
simply given by the number of type F
parents in the previous generation and
the number of offspring when they chose
a versus B and if you use the law of
large numbers you can actually show very
easily that ultimately the growth rate
of type F individuals is given by the
expected logarithm of the F of XA times
1 minus f of X B and so if you want to
find the F that grows the fastest you
just have to optimize this growth rate
as a function of F
it turns out that this geometric growth
rate is a globally concave function in F
so it's got a unique maximum and you can
actually calculate it very easily it's
high school algebra if X a over xB is
defined as the variable R you can think
of R is the relative benefits of X
versus X be the number of offspring of X
a versus X B it's a random variable
there will be yes so this is a random
variable so it turns out that the
optimal growth rate the optimal behavior
the behavior that maximizes the growth
rate f star is going to be equal to 1 if
the expectation of R is greater than 1
and the expectation of the reciprocal is
less than 1 so this is your question
about the means if it turns out that XA
is much better than xB and much better
it means the expected ratio is greater
than 1 and the expected reciprocal is
less than 1 that means that a is going
to be much better than B in terms of the
number of offspring that means that in
order to maximize your growth rate you
really should pick a all the time if the
reverse is true then you should pick B
all the time but because it's a random
variable this can happen you can
actually have the expectation of R being
greater than equal to 1 and the
expectation of the reciprocal of our
being less than or equal to 1 and if
that happens I'm sorry greater than
equal to 1 both of them can be greater
than equal to 1 if that happens then the
optimal solution the solution that
maximizes the growth rate is to
randomize with this particular level of
randomization F star is going to be the
solution to this implicit equation and
so this looks a lot like an euler
equation from an economic expected
utility maximization but there's no no
utility going on this is merely a
process of selection and effectively
what you're gonna be doing is equalizing
the expected number of offspring for XA
versus xB depending on your choice of
Ahlers week Michael you say what role
your assumption about there being a
common draws from yes
huge huge role more specifically if you
didn't have that a right private rose
with this middle case go away
well yes it would concentration exactly
right so your can you hold off five
minutes because I'm gonna come back back
that's a huge in a hugely important case
and then I'll get to yes but for now
what this says is that there are
circumstances where you will not pick a
for-sure or be for sure you will
randomized so let me give you a very
quick illustration this just shows that
for any other behavior you can show that
the number of F Prime's are going to be
vanishingly small relative to F star
that is f star will take over the
population geometrically fast okay
so let me just give you a simple example
of that and then show you some of the
other implications that you are already
getting at so here's an example that I
came up with to try to develop intuition
for what's going on here suppose you
have a very simple ecology where you've
got a seventy five percent chance of
sunshine and a twenty five percent
chance of rain and suppose in this very
simple environment the creature that is
involved has to make a simple decision
about where to build its nest and the
creature has two choices to build the
nest in the valley or on top of a
plateau and the nice thing about the
valley is that it has shade and it also
has a stream with water so in case it
it's sunny then your offspring if you
build your nest in the valley will be
three because the valley protects your
offspring from the deadly rays of the
Sun and there's plenty of water so your
offspring will be able to survive and
therefore you'll be able to successfully
reproduce on the other hand if it rains
and you build your nest in the valley
that's bad news you're gonna be extinct
because in that case the river floods
drowning your offspring so that's bad
news it's exactly the opposite if you
build your nest on top of a plateau on
top of a plateau when the Sun is out
your offspring will burn to death
there's no water on the plateau Dalal
evaporate so that
either died of thirst or exposure but if
it rains and you're on top of the
plateau that's good news because the
cloud will protect your offspring from
the Sun and there'll be rain and so your
offspring will have plenty to drink
all right so 75% chance of sunshine 25%
chance of rain you are the optimizing
efficient economists deciding where to
build your nest where should you build
your nest always in the valley always
build your nest in the valley because
that's got the highest probability of
survival if you want to maximize the
number of offspring you've got you
should always always pick the valley
well let's see what happens so I'm gonna
run a simulation with a lot of different
behaviors so f equal to 0.2 F equal to
0.5 every to the point 75 and here are
the economists F equal to 1 always build
your nest in the valley well that's a
different kind of utility function now
you've got intergenerational
considerations let me come back to that
all right there is a way to trick it so
that you can get to the ultimate bottom
line but for the selfish optimizing one
period maximizers this is what you get
the economists they tend to grow the
fastest they grow faster faster faster
faster to take over the population
whoops
until something happens what happened
what happened of course is that it
rained sorry
I teach MBA students so I have to have
sound effects
the first time it rains the entire
population of economists get wiped out
maybe a good thing depending on your
point of view what this suggests is that
optimizing behavior this kind of very
selfish one period optimizing behavior
is not sustainable because the first
time that it rains and getting back to
Michael's point because you've got
shared risk you're all part of the same
ecosystem the same ecological niche as
soon as it rains you're all wiped out
this behavior no longer exists in the
population and because I'm assuming that
there's no mutation this behavior never
comes back so I'll get back to mutation
a limit later on it turns out that the
behavior that grows the fastest is the
one where you match the probability of
sunshine F equal to 0.75 and again the
reason that works is because in this
case you're actually equalizing the
expected number of offspring per
population in both potential States of
the world the mathematical framework is
very simple in our model if you assume
that fee is also a binomial you actually
get this situation where in state of the
state of the world where it is sunny em
offspring or zero in the state of the
world where it's rainy zero versus M if
you assume this for Phi what you get is
that the optimal behavior is to match
probabilities probability matching comes
out of this very very simple framework
now of course this is a function of
these very very specific parameters and
the fact that the outcomes are
anti-correlated
across the two states of the world it's
that there is no clear winner in terms
of a versus B it depends on the
environment it depends on the risk no
actually if yes there isn't so so it
turns out that zero makes it easier for
me to explain how the behavior
disappears but
if you make it more general tso CA 1 CA
B 1 CA 2 CB 2 and you assume that the
relative values are r1 and r2 it turns
out that you can solve based on our very
simple framework you can actually
calculate the optimal behavior it looks
like this and probability matching
occurs when this F star is approximately
equal to P and that will happen when
these two conditions occur so this is
more than you ever wanted to know about
probability matching this basically
solves for all types of environments
every point on this graph is a
particular set of parameters for that
distribution Phi and so this is where
the relative outcome of a versus B under
the state of the world one where it's
sunny this is the outcome of a versus B
when it's rainy it turns out that if a
is much better than B in both states of
the world
you always pick one if it's always worse
in that state of the world you always
pick 0 and this black line right here
that line is exact probability matching
for every combination of the various
different parameters you will get exact
probability matching in between these
two white curves you'll get
randomization but it won't be exact
probability matching exactly that's
right it is non generic it's non generic
in the sense that depending on the
environment you can get very different
behavior so if the environment looks
like this
you look like economists if the
environment looks like this you look
quite irrational and if the environment
is in between here you look very very
indecisive but the fact is that it's the
environment that's driving this that's
really the point of this that the nature
of the risks actually matter a great
deal and by the way this also seems from
a very primitive perspective to look a
lot like altruism in a strange way
remind remember this is all mindless
right there's no social interaction
there's no strategic decision-making but
think about the way that the narrative
plays out for this
versus Plateau discussion so imagine
we're all part of the same generation
and we're all deciding where to nest and
we over many many generations have come
up with F star of 0.75 that's who we are
so the discussion will go something like
this okay
some of us are gonna go into the valley
75% of us in fact 25% needs to go up in
the plateau so you get back there you go
up to the plateau the chances are you're
not going to survive but it's for the
good of the group so please take one for
the team and go up there and they do it
sounds like altruism that 25% that goes
on the plateau because they have a very
large chance of not surviving there's
nothing there's nothing going on though
of that type it's not a social
interaction it's simply selection nature
selecting based upon systematic risk now
let me get to Michael's point rational
under the circumstances yes it is
rational given that rational in the
sense that it will maximize your
survival but from a but when you're
taking a look at the behavior the
behavior may not correspond to what you
think of as rational for a given
instance if you understand what's going
on with the selection process yes you
can interpret it that way but for the
same reason that if you're on the black
line it is rational to randomize but it
looks like it's irrational from the
perspective of one period survival from
a multi period per spekt if you have a
different preference function if you
construct the infinite horizon
preference function where you care about
the infinite future you can concoct a
mechanism where it looks rational from
that perspective but we don't need to do
that Occam's razor says this is a
simpler explanation for how that emerges
but the way I understood it that's
really what we're always taking B that's
right B is much much better
there's nothing irrational about it but
my point about the irrationality comment
is that you're talking about
deterministic behavior now and
deterministic behavior if you interpret
it as you know something that doesn't
correspond to your intuition about what
you ought to be doing it makes seem as
if it's irrational you're optimizing
over the you're not optimizing over
individual one period outcomes your what
you're trying to do is to capture the
survival rates of the various different
individuals so yes this you you it's
fine to call this rational but we have
to actually define what we mean by
rational and I haven't talked about that
yet all I'm saying is that what I'm
selecting what nature is selecting on is
long term survival
whereas in fact what we think about as
rational irrational has to do with the
context of the individual decision when
X star is 0 isn't isn't that exactly the
case where you're also maximizing your
next generation in this case yes in this
case yes and in this case yes in between
the white lines no when you call red
irrational because you're maximizing
both kinds of rationality you're right
sorry I misspoke absolutely this does
look rational from the economics
perspective as does this in this case
because in this case there's no doubt
that a dominates be the area where
there's irrationalities in between the
white lines where it's not clear now
what looks rational irrational but from
a survival perspective it is clear ok so
let me get to the point that Michael
made which is if I make one simple
change in my assumption if I change the
assumption that you and I in the same
population in the same generation have
identical distributions to we have
independent and identical distributions
it turns out these results go away the
so-called irrationality of mixed
strategies it really depends heavily on
this assumption so now I'm going to
change this and make it iid instead of
the perfectly dependent perfectly
identically distributed so essentially
what I'm assuming is idiosyncratic
reproductive risk meaning that your draw
is different from my draw it's the same
distribution but it's a statistically
independent draw so when you do that the
population arithmetic changes in a very
very minor way but has major
implications instead of the same draw
for all of us in the same generation
that pick a we now have individual
random variables and so when you apply
the law of large numbers within a given
generation you don't get a random
variable anymore
now you get the mean of that random
variable and therefore the growth rate
here it's non stochastic in which case
if you want to optimize the growth rate
F is like either zero if nu B is greater
than mu a or it's one if mu a is greater
than mu B you get a termina stick
solution and so in this example here
when it corresponds to in terms of the
iid assumption is now you and I were not
part of the same Valley or the same
plateau we each have our own
microclimate sort of like the way it is
here in California you know whether
you're you know in the bay or whatever
you know on the coast or in the
mountains you have very different kinds
of environments when you run the
simulation now what you find is that
economists end up ruling the day they
grow faster than all of the other
elements because the probability that
that all of the economists get wiped out
at the same time is vanishingly small
given that they have iid drawers so
another way of putting this is that when
nature is systematic when nature forces
you into an environment where you're all
facing the same risk your behavior has
to diversify that kind of risk you can't
afford to be systematic as well when
nature is idiosyncratic that's when you
can afford to be systematic so another
way of putting it is nature of bores and
undiversified bet
Economist's notion of diversification
and systematic versus idiosyncratic
exactly yes approach might get me to
choose F equals 1 when risk is video
syncretic and data choose it does I
don't mean to be ungenerous economists
but but the reason that I don't talk
about the economic intuition here is
because the economic condition relies on
an assumption of risk aversion and
utility functions which is why you care
about diversification this is much more
primitive you don't need that there's no
assumption of any kind of behavior
whatsoever other than you got all the
behaviors represented but what it does
say is that the economic intuition is
actually very important and it carries
over in a much more general way so for
example the sharp cap M and the role of
systemic risk that actually has much
more importance apart above and beyond
equilibrium theory
you don't need equilibrium in order to
show why systemic risk is important if
you want to yes that's right there is a
relationship but the relationship is not
one-to-one we have a paper that were
working on that shows the origin of blog
utility from this framework but the
reason that this works and the reason
this is so similar is because what
you're doing what nature does is to
maximize the geometric growth rate of a
population and that's tantamount to
essentially nature having log utility
that that's going on but the the utility
here is really just the population it's
not any kind of function that we're
arbitrarily imposing so I'm I'm just
about out of time so let me just try to
wrap up very quickly and talk about
bounded rationality and intelligence so
as I mentioned Herbert Simon was the the
first person who proposed this notion of
satisficing as an alternative to
optimization but his work has actually
had less impact in economics at least
when it first came out is I think more
and more people are appreciating the
importance of what he's done now but he
had a big impact on AI and part of the
reason that economists would dismiss his
work originally was because his notion
of satisficing didn't contain any
particular mechanism for coming up with
the appropriate heuristics he just said
that your wrist except to be good enough
but the question is how how do they come
become good enough where you get them
from and we propose that this
evolutionary framer can actually
describe where that comes from so the
idea that I first started talking about
which is that your behavior this
Bernoulli trial a versus B is
statistically independent of everything
that's mindless behavior what if we
allow your decision to actually be
correlated with the random variables of
your offspring so in other words what if
it's the case that every time you chose
X a it actually happened to be better
than X B and every time you chose X B it
happened to be better than X a in other
words what if you had predictive power
to be able to figure out whether or not
a is gonna be better than B so
effectively you knew which was gonna
have the higher mean for example you had
information that's what we're calling
intelligence it's basically the ability
to forecast a versus B and it turns out
that there's a very natural evolutionary
definition of intelligence from this
framework it's anything that gives you a
reproductive advantage and you can see
that by defining what stupidity is the
opposite of intelligence what do we mean
by stupid it's these kinds of behaviors
right so two folks in the bathtub or the
pool they've got the nice stereo going
and they've got an extension cord on
these slippers right in the middle of
the water very smart you know or
somebody here taking a picture of an
alligator here fixing the car with a
piece of wood propped up these are
examples of behavior that we call stupid
why because they're counterproductive to
survival so if if that's what we mean by
intelligence that is it gives you a
reproductive advantage we can actually
incorporate that in our model very
simply if we allow
covariance between our actions and the
outcomes to be greater than zero
that's intelligence right there it gives
you a reproductive success an advantage
and so it turns out that you can
actually analyze that in the framework
of our context of the model where you
basically have correlation now between
your action and the outcomes and you can
show that obviously if you get that
correlation to be one you're gonna grow
the fastest in general we can't make the
correlation equal to one so there's some
nonlinear surface that will allow
various different state variables to
give us predictive power that gives us
various kinds of behaviors that could be
optimal because we have different
methods of forecasting XA versus xB okay
lots of other extensions including
mutation a strategic behavior we've
assumed that your actions have no
bearing on my actions and outcomes if it
turns out that we change that assumption
so that when I choose something that
affects your outcome out of that will
emerge strategic behavior and planning
and forward-looking and all that kind of
stuff the most important extension that
we're working on now is actually to
change this framework to think about not
just one choice at a time but to string
a bunch of choices together so it's easy
these are all Bernoulli choices if you
bring them together you get a binomial
tree you can imagine that now the kind
of behaviors you can get are much much
more complex it's not just a versus B
but you get binary strings of behavior
and of course that looks a lot like
human thought it's evolution at the
speed of thought that's where we hope to
go with this to be able to provide a
little bit more of a generalization for
the framework thank you
touched on this a little bit at the end
untrue but I think I totally eat I
totally on board with the idea that
evolution have a role to play and
understanding the way we operate and
reason but you didn't you didn't get
into computational limitations yes so
that's actually the last part that I had
to rush over since we're running out of
time the idea is that if you think about
correlation as being a source of
intelligence in other words my actions
actually end up being positively
correlated with good outcomes then the
question is how do you get that
correlation that's where computational
limits come in in the if there's no
limit to resources physiological or
environmental I should be able to drive
that correlation to one I can predict
perfectly when I'm gonna miscarriage
versus when I'm gonna have a great set
of offspring but the fact is that we
don't we can't do that because of these
limitations so computational limits I
would think of them as more
environmental constraints as well as
physiological constraints that actually
imposes a constraint on the amount of
computing you can do to calculate those
kinds of correlations so you can call
that computational limits but from a
biological perspective that comes about
because you've got environmental and
physiological constraints so I started
out with mindless behavior totally
random and out of that came these you
know risk aversion loss aversion and so
on if instead I made assumptions that my
outcome is actually influenced by your
action what meat what that means is that
over time what will evolve out of that
primordial soup our abilities for you to
engage in certain actions that will
prevent me from reproducing so that you
can reproduce more advantageous ly so if
you assume that there is an ability to
have memory and if you assume that that
ability allows you to engage in pattern
recognition then
again assuming all sorts of behavior
including that kind of behavior you'll
find that strategic planning and
forward-looking behavior will emerge out
of that process there isn't well so that
that correlation function that I showed
you correlation is a function of lots of
state variables so you can be better
predictor because you're you're faster
you're stronger
you've got visual acuity you've got lots
of different advantages there are many
different ways of creating that
correlation it doesn't matter from an
evolutionary perspective where the
correlation comes from it just matters
that every time you choose a you
actually have it a survival advantage so
what that suggests that there are many
different kinds of creatures that will
emerge each with its own way of
advantageous ly choosing a versus B so
yes there won't be a unique kind of
individual there'll be many forms of
intelligence if you will yes yeah so so
we didn't get do that but that's a pape
one of the things that were working on
the way that we get sex sex first of all
is very good you probably already knew
that I don't have to tell you the reason
that sex is good is because in this
model without sex once a particular
behavior disappears it never comes back
but if you allow for mutations so we
have another model which says that your
offspring 99.9 percent of time if you're
an F your offspring is an F but 0.1% of
the time it's not an F it's anything
other than an F uniformly between zero
and one if you make that one assumption
it turns out that first of all all
behaviors are always represented in a
population first of all and second of
all here's the other really weird thing
that I think biologists understand
intuitively but but we didn't it turns
out that there is no optimal growth rate
any longer it turns out that if you
introduce mutation everything grows at
exactly the same rate all the FS
grow at the same rate slightly less than
f star without mutation but you can
prove that and what's going on there is
that mutation is basically nature's
insurance policy there in other words no
matter what the environment is there
will always be some behavior that will
be optimal for that environment whereas
before if I didn't have mutation if the
environment shifts it could possibly it
could be that everybody gets wiped out
so we actually are able to derive the
optimal mutation rate as a function of
how easily or how much the environment
shifts from one to the other so mutation
actually changes everything and the kind
of behaviors that you get ultimately end
up being a lot more complicated you
don't have a single F star anymore all
of the FS actually grow at the same rate
that doesn't mean they you have the same
population it's random it changes over
time and we can characterize the
limiting distribution using organic
theory so that that's a paper that is in
the works we're happy to send you copies
if you're interested yes the first part
where you talk about the probability
matching for humans so there's the
prospect theory sort of low
probabilities get over very high
probabilities here underrated suppose
how does that factor into this framework
because there should be some kind of
adjustment right so so our view is that
human decision-making is a lot more
complicated because layered on top of
this very primitive mechanism are lots
of other mechanisms as I showed you
every time you change the parameters of
that fire distribution you actually
change the behavior so what we're trying
to do now is experiments very simple
probability matching experiments where
we change the reward structure to see
whether or not we can generate that kind
of behavior
so neural plasticity is a fancy way of
saying that you know we adapt to
changing environmental conditions and so
over time I believe that evolution has
given us the ability to do that to
change so there's multiple mechanisms
that we have and it's very complicated
to tell what the mechanism is is unless
you understand what the environment is
once you define the environment the fie
distribution you should be able to
figure out what the behavior will emerge
that will be optimal relative to that
environment what you say seems really
surprising to me and I'm gonna
understand up there so if you're saying
it all over hips grow at the same rate
but seems that there's some is really
stupid exactly at least for some
environments maybe even dominated ifs so
how can those grow at the same rate of
something there because the environment
shifts over time and so once the
environment shifts that particular F
will not be optimal and so the in the
limit as you have all of these shifts
going on the only way that you can have
equilibrium that you can when you
optimize they all grow at the same rate
yes yes it does
no no it's it's not general in the sense
that we're assuming that the environment
changes over time there's some kind of
stochastic change in the environment
well the rate of mutation is gonna be
linked to the amount of change so for
example if the environment never changes
then mutation doesn't really benefit you
the fee function if the fee function is
stable over time then mutation doesn't
benefit you but if the fee function
shifts over time then mutation will by
benefit I mean it will allow some
species to survive and so that's why
it's there if you assume that there
exists some mechanism for which species
will survive this is the mechanism that
will allow that to emerge yes back to a
couple of the only questions but
sometimes trying to stand the relation
between this and some of the earlier
kind of market selections so like like
the bloomin easily type of work where
even if you don't have utilities the
investors who balance their wealth
correctly across options
groph everyone else's so they end up
with a larger share of the wealth in the
market right so it's it's it's related
in one sense that they're making the
same kind of argument but their focus is
on a particular kind of utility
functions and their their definition of
survival is money what we're using is a
much more primitive notion of survival
and based upon the different
environments we're getting lots of
different kinds of behaviors so in their
model it's been a while since I've read
it but in their model I believe they
assume that you've got you know hedge
fund managers that have logged utility
and you've got normal people that have
risk aversion coefficients of constant
relative risk aversion two to five to
ten and in that setting the folks that
survive are the hedge fund managers
because they're the ones that are taking
the biggest risks so what we're doing is
a bit more general in the sense that
we're allowing for different kinds of
environmental conditions and we can
generate their results from what we do
but we can actually show in certain
conditions that not only will the hedge
fund managers dominate but nobody else
will survive in other conditions the
hedge fund managers won't survive it'll
actually be the risk-averse individuals
that will thank you